وزير الخارجيه الامريكان زياره لبيجين
كانت مقرره يوم امس الجمعه بعدها رصد من
طرد صيني في الاجواء الامريكيه وكانت جوله
بلينك ستشكل الزياره الاولى لوزير خارجيه
الى الصين منذ عام 2018
[موسيقى]
مراقبه صيني تصرفنا لحمايه معلوماتنا
الحساسه وتواصلنا مع الصينيين وتواصلت
فرقنا مع الجهات المعنيه توصلنا الى ان
الظروف غير مناسبه لزياره بناءه الى الصين
في مثل هذا الوقت اوضحت للنظير الصيني ان
وجود مثل هذا المنطاد هو انتهاك لسياده
بلدنا وعمل غير مسؤول خاصه قبل زيارته الى
الصين
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الذي زمن الولايات
المتحده بنهج الدبلوماسيه مع الصين وانها
ستبقى تبقي على خطوط اتصال مفتوحه مع
الصين ايضا الى ان زيارته لا تزال قائمه
لكن حين تسمح الظروف بذلك
الولايات المتحده تظل ملتزمه بالدبلوماسيه
مع الصين واخطط لزياره بيج عندما تسمح
الظروف بذلك في الان ذاته سنواصل الحفاظ
على خطوط اتصال مفتوحه مع الصين لاهداف
منها معالجه هذا الحادث بهذا السبب نحتاج
الى اتصالات مباشره ومنتظمه ومن المهم ان
تظل هذه الخطوط مفتوحه في جميع الاوقات
لتجنب الصراع والسقوط في حسابات خاطئه
العالم يريد من الولايات المتحده والصين
اداره علاقتهما بمسؤوليه ومعالجه العديد
من التحديات العالميه تتطلب ايجاد طريقه
للعمل معا وسنواصل التصرف بطريقه تعكس هذه
المسؤوليه